pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
harry a accueilli le plus parisien des
présidents des républiques d'amérique
latine
aujourd'hui président de la république
péruvienne monsieur manuel prado a passé
jadis de longues années dans la capitale
française
le président dont le premier geste a été
de se recueillir au côté du général de
gaulle sur la tombe du soldat inconnu
s'est toujours montré même aux heures
les plus graves un grand ami de la
france
je suis aux côtés de la france libre
affirmé t-il dès 1941 avant d'être un an
plus tard le premier chef d'état
américain a déclaré la guerre aux forces
de la ce
[Musique]
nous l'avions de voir son nom associé à
celui de oued smar en algérie l'une des
plus anciennes fabriques de serrures de
france va en effet se prolonger par delà
la méditerranée marquant ainsi une date
dans l'histoire de l'industrialisation
algérienne l'entreprise moulinoise est
en effet la 200e a installé une
succursale en algérie
housemarque elle offrira 80 emplois
nouveaux à la main d'oeuvre locale
là
[Musique]
c'est à seize mille 500 au total que
ceux ci feront les emplois nouveaux
créés par les 200 entreprises en cours
d'installation sur le sol algérien et
qui représente en investissement la
valeur de 44 milliards d'anciens francs
le plan de constantine se développe le
monde agricole bouffe fort de
représenter à la fois le quart de la
nation est le septième du revenu
français
les paysans veulent voir le gouvernement
se penchait sur leur sort tel était
l'objet de la manifestation qui a réuni
à amiens trente mille d'entre eux le
défilé dans les rues ne devait pourtant
pas garder l'aspect pacifique que lui
avait fixé les dirigeants de la
manifestation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de violentes bagarres devait éclater
opposant les manifestants au barrage des
forces de l'ordre
le rôle de provocateur étrangers aux
milieux ruraux a été par la suite mise
en évidence
ils portent la responsabilité des
violences qui ont fait 150 blessés
[Musique]
atta
oui
au large du lavandou à quelque 3 km en
mer plongeurs et chasseurs sous-marins
se donne volontiers rendez vous par
l'unfp mètres de fond près d'une épave
de l'avant dernière guerre c'était pas
possède d'ailleurs un autre intérêt son
concierge ce concierge est un mérou de
bétail qui loge dans un trou de la coque
et qui a fini par nous et amitié avec
l'un de ses visiteurs réguliers les eaux
millan directeur de l'école de plongée
du lavandou
puis à force de patience et d'adressent
a réussi à apprivoiser cet animal
généralement peu sociable
[Musique]
l'homme est le poisson faut maintenant
bon ménage sinon table commune et
prospère c'est le nom du mérou vient
comme un bon chien vous manger dans la
main sans même craindre la caméra de
jean foucher credo
[Musique]
le 13 à 7 heures du matin la france
faisait éclater sa bombe atomique
comment fut acquis cette réussite qui
place la france aux côtés des trois
grands atomique
voici l'histoire des cinquante deux le
commissariat à l'énergie nucléaire
la mission de réaliser l'engin pour
l'étude duquel aucune aide étrangère
n'était à espérer
par bonheur la france dispose
d'importants gisements d'uranium restait
la transformation lusine du boucher
assure à cette transformation d'uranium
minerai en uranium métal destiné à
servir de combustible nucléaire dans les
piles de marque
[Musique]
marc houle était née d'abord équipé
d'une seule pile ga
mais les années suivantes devait lui
ajouter deux grandes piles g2 et g3
chacune d'une puissance de 200 mille
kilos à de chaleur c'est dans ces trois
piles que fut élaboré le plutonium
nécessaire pour manipuler ce plutonium
corps particulièrement dangereux furent
créés des laboratoires entièrement
enterré dans leur partie essentielle
ces laboratoires de réalisation ultra
moderne comporte des séries de cellules
où se poursuivent les travaux sur
substances radioactives
chacune renferme un ensemble d'enceintes
spécial étanche appelés boîtes à gants à
l'intérieur desquels les manipulations
s'effectue en atmosphère neutre
[Musique]
chacun de ces travaux était la suite ou
le résultat d'études faites à l'aide d'
accélérateur de particules des types les
plus variés études rendues nécessaires
par le silence des puissances atomiques
l'un de ces problèmes est le plus
délicat peut-être était le calcul de la
masse critique de plutonium destiné à
entrer dans la constitution de l'engin
calcul qui nécessite à l'emploi de
calculateurs électroniques véritable
cerveau artificiel capable d'effectuer
les opérations les plus complexes
mais
[Musique]
pendant ce temps et dans le secret le
plus absolu
la base de reggane s'organiser il avait
fallu pour établir ce polygone
d'expérimentation une zone très étendue
ou sur des milliers de kilomètres carrés
toute vie était absent le sud du sahara
remplissait ses conditions de sécurité
mieux que les espaces du nevada de
l'asie centrale est de l'australie
[Musique]
en moins de deux années malgré les
difficultés géographiques qui imposèrent
la mise en oeuvre de moyens énormes la
base vie celle où devaient vivre et
travailler les hommes de la bombe devait
être aménagé et dotée en plein désert
d'un confort indispensable des hommes
qui allaient vivre loin de tout il
fallut à coup de bulldozer et deux
camions faire des terrassements
considérable utiliser d'énormes masses
de béton rechercher les points d'eau et
les canaliser construire logements et
laboratoires équipés électriquement tous
les locaux aménagés les lieux de travail
et les lieux de repos les dizaines de
kilomètres de route furent construits
pour le transport du matériel lourd un
conte aérodrome établi pour la mise en
place d'un pont aérien permettant
d'amener hommes matériel et
ravitaillement et regan se mit à vivre
pour le jour j
dans ses laboratoires souterrains les
expérimentateurs pur mettre la dernière
main à la finition de la bombe pendant
qu'à quelques dizaines de kilomètres
d'énormes travaux commençaient à
circonscrire le point zéro au milieu la
tour de fer qui supportera la bombe
autour les blockhaus des appareils
enregistreurs les enveloppes de béton
pour les caméras ultra rapide qui
retraceront image par image
le développement de l'opération afin de
tirer tous les enseignements sur les
effets de l'expérience on a exposé
autour du point zéro différents
matériels militaires
tout désormais est en place depuis les
équipes de décontamination jusqu'au
équipe chargée d'opérer avant et après
l'opération certains relèvements
ce n'est plus qu'une question de jours
et bientôt terre voici maintenant que
l'heure h est proche
vous vivez dans le blockhaus de la mise
à feu la minute solennelle de la
première explosion atomique française
certes on pourra déplorer la pauvreté
des images qui nous ont été fournies sur
l'explosion dont on ne verra qu'un
panache de fumée cela ne retire rien au
fait seul avec ses seuls moyens la
france à fabriquer sa bombe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]